what to add to that holiday shopping
list for all ages who better to ask than
lifestyle expert and mom of three amanda
mushroom and this season she's also got
the answer all of his parents with
little ones have been asking for when it
comes to elf on the shelf
[Music]
if you have kids who love
the elf on the shelf like my kids are
obsessed you want to check out elfmates
this is adorable story and three elves
and it's all about kindness and doing
good deeds and here's the best part kids
can actually play with these elves
because the magic of the elf on the
shelf is you can't touch that elf but
these ones were sent by santa so kids
can hug them they can pose them so cute
it's from the makers of elf on the shelf
it's like they find they've listened
like listen kids really want to touch
these elves so a great message really
fun toy
and then my kids have really been
getting into puzzles so we've been
trying to find puzzles that they want to
make and that i want to put together
with them and i love these from why wow
these are their super sized puzzles and
they come in really fun brands like
kool-aid it just makes me laugh
i mean how cute is this it's made out of
100 recycled
uh puzzle board so again i love that
idea of sustainability if you're looking
for a gift for the adults because we
don't want to leave them out how about a
game night but this one is just for
adults this is for our 18 and older
crowd this is socially twisted
so this is a really fun game you get a
story card and you get a word card and
you have to use the words in the story
it's so funny but perfect for a girls
night or if you're having friends over
crazy funny sometimes wildly
inappropriate
but that's a really fun one definitely
for adults and then what is more
impressive under the tree
whatever you see like a scooter or a
bike i am love this is the fluid scooter
i mean how fun the fluid liner scooter
scooter this one can go up to 18 miles
per hour so this is definitely the one
that you want for maybe your teen or
young adults now i have to say my
husband was scooting around
on this right before this segment and i
was like you're middle aged
three kids get off of that thing
for all ages right there's also oddbods
echo blocks ecoblocks hello for
preschoolers and a stem challenge with
the candy claw machine for tweens